a small plane crash caused a near
disaster in northern New Jersey the
twin-engine plane plunged into a home in
Colonia yesterday about 20 miles
southwest of New York City
the pilot identified as dr. michael
schloss was killed but no one else was
hurt
mola legi is at the crash scene Lola
what are we hear from people close by
well good morning Anthony as you can see
behind me here by all of this the street
that the house sits on has been closed
off while authorities investigate the
crash scene the house is just beyond
this police barricade or what's left of
the house now neighbors in the area say
that they heard the plane sputtering and
then a loud bang just to give you an
idea of how devastating how much more
devastating this could have been we're
only about a quarter mile from a grammar
school that was in session at the time
of the crash this surveillance video
captured the moment the small
twin-engine Cessna plane nosedived just
before 11:00 a.m. this was the aftermath
a suburban New Jersey home on fire after
the plane crashed through the roof
tearing through two floors into the
basement I heard it hit and then you got
this loud like sonic boom and shook all
the houses it kind of looks like a
volcano erupted the plane took off from
Leesburg Virginia at around 9:50 Tuesday
morning it was supposed to land at
linden airport in new jersey before it
crashed about three and a half miles
away
the pilot was communicating with air
traffic control and was cleared for an
approach and the airplane subsequently
lost radar contact the family of three
who lived at the house luckily wasn't
there when the plane hit Mayor John
McCormick says the home was engulfed in
flames in just seconds everybody was
home I don't know if they would have had
a chance to escape so thank God now the
NTSB will spend the next few days
sorting through the rubble as we pull
that wreckage out piece by piece we'll
be examining the condition of those
components such as the flight controls
the engine everything that we can find
now the plane is expected to be removed
from the crash scene in the next two or
three days that could take a little
longer because of the poor weather in
the area
meanwhile the first preliminary report
on exactly
what happened why the plane went down
how it went down that's expected in
about ten days Tony so we should learn a
little more than very fortunate that
family wasn't home Ola thank you very
much